une quinzaine de maisons côté ukrainien
éventrés par des obus soufflées par les
explosions
témoin des nouveaux incidents sur la
ligne de front même image de l'autre
côté chez les séparatistes pro-russes
les fenêtres de cette habitation ont été
pulvérisés dans la nuit bon match à tous
était silencieux je suis allé pour
fermer ma porte et quand je suis arrivé
au
papa de j'ai entendu le bombardement
dans ce conflit larvé est cette escalade
de la violence il y as peut-être une
avancée diplomatique dans la nuit
l'elysée annonce qu'à l'initiative d'
emmanuel macron un sommet va se tenir
entre vladimir poutine et joe biden il
est 1h 47 les prises dans bye donné
poutine ont chacun accepté le principe
d'un tel sommet il ne pourra se tenir
que si la russie n'envahit pas l'ukraine
une information confirmée par les états
unis qui disent gardé une porte ouverte
pour une solution diplomatique
le président by john l'a dit très
clairement il est prêt rencontré poutine
n'importe quand et n'importe où si ça
peut aider à éviter la guerre
mais la route vers la paix est encore
longue ce matin le kremlin dément parler
d'une annonce prématurée et reproche
même à l'ukraine d'avoir détruit l'un de
ces postes frontières la guerre de
l'information continue les ukrainiens
eux diffuse cette vidéo ces explosions
distille ce sont les russes tirant des
obus sur leurs propres positions afin
d'accuser les ukrainiens comment
analyser aussi ses photos satellites on
y voit l'armée russe aux frontières de
l'ukraine qui s'est dispersé peut être
le signe d'un retrait ou au contraire
d'une invasion imminente